you look great that beer looks nice oh
thank you so much you are you're always
handsome so oh you're not dead you know
that oh yes it is always good to be
chatting with caramel brown
after you're doing et Canada can you
also just come over and co-host coromo
show with me
four of me I want to make sure that
you're walking away better than I found
you I saw that Kelly Clarkson who is the
queen of daytime TV gave you the most
warm welcome I am a Kelly stand
um not fan stand
and Kelly isn't the only celeb sending
luck to caramo Forever
talk show host and by the way I'd know a
little about that this is my mean wall
hey all those Emmys I mean yes no big
deal just flexing with Phil Donna here
and of course karamo's queer eye
co-hosts also shared a lot of love Tang
got emotional for me because he knew it
was my dream I've been saying it since
the first day Bobby was just screaming
and you know like crazy and I think that
was also the first two I told but
Jonathan was so supportive and so is
Anthony I asked you that question about
what life did you build in your head
about your child because that life and
that thought pattern and any feelings
you had attached to the LGBT community
are showing their head now it's super
important when you have a space like
this in daytime television to cover
topics that are incredibly important and
impactful to people across the world it
is something that I personally believe
is part of the mission of me having this
show is to make sure that people
understand that members of the queer
Community are just like the rest of us
we are beings who deserve love and
respect